L'univers de la WWE préparez-vous à rencontrer la prochaine
grande superstar Leo tu vas être en retard,
gamin, il est déjà temps de se lever déjà papa blague Oh c'est notre petit
petit c'est d'être une superstar de la WWE récupère
ça allez on va t'avoir
Thompson
[Musique]
eh bien, ces pouvoirs mathématiques ne fonctionnent que pour les
concurrents qui méritent sa
magie
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ce masque me rend super
rapide et fou, je vais te casser la
gueule nerd Je pense que tu devrais les laisser
tranquilles c'était le plus cool  chose jamais la
WWE organise un tournoi
gagnant-gagnant le gagnant deviendra la prochaine
superstar de la WWE continuez à courir continuez à
courir continuez à courir ne regardez pas ce
gars affronte ce gars à travers le chaos frère
ne posez pas de questions vos réponses  trop
ça va être plus facile que je ne le pensais je
plaisante juste bonne chance à aucun de vous
le masque magique n'est pas ce qui vous rend
fort la vraie sangle vient d'ici et
voici
Samson
bienvenue aux
[Applaudissements]
wow tu as très faim hein  ok je
veux dire porter  ing beaucoup de couleurs
[Musique]
vous